most unemployment claimants were
expecting a long pause in payments due
to the timing of the stimulus bill
becoming a reality
now some claimants did get paid this
week with the extra weekly benefits
joe mohler live outside the deter
offices he joins us with an update
joe yeah we've been getting a lot of
questions about the changes that are
coming with this
stimulus bill well dieter has been
working on the changes they need to do
on their website and much
more and this week some claimants
started seeing benefits and those extra
weekly payments
we are all pleasantly surprised because
theater kind of knocked this one out of
the park this time
amber hansen runs a popular unemployment
facebook group that has over 19 000
followers
they got this implemented literally with
no gap
in benefits and we saw the ui side start
seeing their benefits as of tuesday
stimulus bill changes are being made by
dieter people who had remaining eligible
weeks left before the bill happened
had payments continued this week when
many were expecting a long pause and
payments
people also started getting the extra
300 weekly payments
hanson says she recently was told what
changes were being made from someone on
the deter strike force
what i'm obviously gathering from the
experience is that
they have obviously been working with
the vendor to try to get this i guess
theater
wanted to set the tone and wanted to be
one of the first states to get this done
from what i was told
thursday the head of the department said
in part quote we know nevadans need help
i'm so proud of the dedicated staff at
dieter who worked over the holidays so
nevada could be one of the first states
in the country
to implement this added benefit as
changes happen dieter is still waiting
for more guidance from the department of
labor so more changes are expected
a complete finish could take a few more
weeks as far as extended programs if you
were forced into the seb benefits you
will get the peuc benefits
you had before automatically peter says
claimants should continue to file their
weekly claims
we want to continue to see them build
momentum on getting through those
appeals getting through that backlog of
first-time filers
we do have more information from that
release in addition to more information
on the extended benefits for those of
you on
peuc or sep just head to our website and
click on this story that's
eightnewsnow.com
and we do also want to talk about
appeals really quick uh hanson also says
that some appeals for pua claimants are
starting but you have to check your
portal
for the update on that that's where
you'll get the notification on your
hearing so keep an eye on that
reporting live in las vegas joe mohler 8
news now